okay
honestly still sticking off
we've had many videos of characters
showing how much they're above the
competition but what about the other
side of the equation what about those
poor souls that have had to see that
power first hand or in much more muted
scenarios what about someone who has an
astounding lead only to blow it due to
Shenanigans or simply being outsmarted
that's what we're going through today
let's go through some of the most
embarrassing defeats in anime let's
start with Reagan vs seventh division
oh my God
[Music]
entering the 12th episode suspense is
high with mob and the group seemingly
faced with unsurmountable odds by the
time the first few minutes were done it
was all over Reagan stands up and let's
just say the seventh division stood no
chance whatsoever after taking mob's
power temporarily the battle against
ishiguro was nothing but a cakewalk who
cares about those black holes when
Reagan can easily nullify them gravity
attacks what a joke after some more
talking Reagan ends it by throwing
ishiguro away and masking him in the
process and all the time our Mentor here
remains completely chill as if he wasn't
even in a fight to the death just
seconds ago doubles as a mental Flex on
being defeated like this with the
numbers game on their side it's got a
hurt
foreign
versus boss
Oken seems to be tailor fit for the big
boss role he's intimidating he has a
penchant for violence and he's one who
relishes in suffering refusing to put
enemies out of their misery this is it
truly the ultimate villain for the
heroes to face in ranking of kings and
he more than proved his worth in his
on-screen exploits nothing stood in his
way and I personally lost track of the
number of characters he'd Fallen against
okin even boji and the big four weren't
able to truly land a decisive blow on
him thanks to good old villain
regeneration he seemed Unstoppable and
he's enjoying every moment of him then
boss comes back and is sword over all
those achievements and Feats in combat
go down the drain and Oaken was
dispatched like some random small fry
while Oaken wouldn't be killed he would
be sealed trapped in a way to prevent
regeneration from demigod to pathetic
fodder real quick
foreign
Luke Valentine's first defeat against
Alucard has to be up there
Luke Valentine sure talks big for a
minor villain yeah Luke's not as loud
and obnoxious as his brother but he's a
big talker in his own right who goes
around claiming that he'll
single-handedly put down Alucard after
all come on man apparently Luke didn't
get the memo on autocad's prowess now
did he well he got his chance to test
his powers out in their first encounter
unfortunately though for Luke he may
have bitten way off more than he could
chew and the resulting fight is not even
close for all the talk he did he
decisively was no match for Alucard who
turns the tide on his condescending
attitude this time it's Alucard mocking
him for being useless and pathetic
before literally feeding him to the dogs
that's not the end of it all either but
let's face it with the pride that's
keeping him afloat gone Luke's finished
[ __ ]
I think a lot of you know it's coming
Frieza versus Trunks
[Applause]
[Music]
no it's not the equally embarrassing
defeat Frieza had against Goku the one
that sees him sliced by his own attack
in that one at least he more than
Justified his status as Ark villain he's
a legitimate threat and he was such a
powerful war for Our Heroes to cross
This Time It's Different returning with
a newly enhanced body and vowing revenge
Frieza runs into not Goku but trunks
Frieza wanted Goku and no one else but
trunks proved to be more than a match
for him this time he was defeated with
little Fanfare his attacks were thrown
back at him and he was easily
eviscerated by this mysterious fighter I
mean it wasn't even a match and I think
this kind of defeat is way more
humiliating than the one he suffered in
his own arc from Ark villain to random
fodder even with a new body and all
Frieza had one big four From Grace
foreign
I'm sure we've had these embarrassing
defeats ourselves right we don't battle
like anime characters do well yeah but
we sure lose out on some amazing deals
that we could have gotten that's where
today's video sponsor slick deals comes
into play snake deals is the largest and
most trusted deal sharing company out
there thanks to their service people
have saved thousands of dollars in their
hunt for the best deals out there by
installing the slick deals browser
extension you can get the best prices
and discounts when you shop online it
allows you to compare sites with one
another in your hand to get the perfect
deal say goodbye to searching for
coupons or cashback points too slick
deals has that part down too and the
extension openly applies the latest
coupon codes Now using it I was able to
get some deals on accessories like this
awesome gaming headset that I got for
half the price the best part about slick
deals is that it also features an always
active ever-growing Community with over
12 million users sharing their
information you can easily get the best
deals available in real time if you're
ready to experience online shopping like
never before then be sure to try out
slick deals get the best prices for your
gaming accessory appliances and such at
your fingertips by downloading the
extension through this link in the
description Luffy versus Bellamy is
quite comedic honestly
why did I find this funny because better
be spent more time talking and bouncing
around than hitting Luffy it's something
if this were a more contested and
intense battle but Luffy and Bellamy is
practically a joke of a fight yeah I
mean it is a joke despite what Bellamy
would suggest otherwise Bellamy does a
great job putting his techniques out
there he does a great job creating a
Ruckus he talks big he talks loud and
gets quite obnoxious at some points one
thing he doesn't do a great job at as
you know is defeating Luffy for all the
bragging he gets put down super easy and
I don't think there's anything more
damaging to your own Pride than going
down like that having knuckle imprints
left on you is the finishing touch to
the embarrassment of being one shot dig
just like that
however even more comedic is saitama
versus Sonic
[Music]
racing after Hammerhead our good friend
speedasonic encounters none other than
saitama the stages set for an epic
showdown one that will crush all of our
assumptions one that will never mind
hype up this showdown as much as I want
we all know what's gonna happen don't we
but the whole point of one punch man is
never in the pretend suspense since
saitama fights in fact this fight turned
out to be one of the most entertaining
fights in the entire first season Sonic
goes all out from the get-go only to
have his pride hurt by saitama seeing
through those attacks feeling more and
more agitated Sonic starts talking
himself up on how he'll kill saitama
only to be met with indifference while
he decides to finish it off with his
ultimate technique such a move will only
prove to be as undoing when saitama
responds with his signature punch to the
crotch now that's gotta her but also
doubles as an extremely comedic moment
coming at the expense of Sonic's dignity
check tomatoes
we're all so used to villains being
humiliated but what about the
protagonists come on in Subaru
you're taking the four here then again
he's just suffering incarnate for most
parts of re zero and an important part
of his development involved him getting
his ass kicked in public it wasn't even
a match at all and Julius just spends
literal minutes on end beating him down
while everyone watches on Subaru may
have kicked ass the previous Arc but
it's all back to Earth for him in this
one and the bad news just keeps coming
for him it's this beat down that further
drove a wedge between him and Emilia and
the two finally have their decisive
conflict right after this event
kick-starting The Last Arc of the first
season hey it's my favorite Arc so I
guess there's some good to be had from
this humiliating defeat it's such a
pivotal moment that often gets lost in
the shuffle because we're all too
enthralled with the whale fight battle
Goose's entire character and rem's
confession Subaru sure had to earn his
happy ending for this arcan it all
started with a public humiliation
[Applause]
Naruto versus giba is another fight that
I found amusing ah
Naruto isn't exactly a match for Kiba if
we're only to look at the first half of
the fight his techniques along with
akamaru proved to be too much for our
Plucky protagonist and after the first
few moments of this Tune-in exam match
things look to be over for Naruto who
gets forced to continually Dodge a
decisive hit prompt keeper to start
trash talking but as people say pride
comes before the fall Naruto is a
strategy however allows him to turn the
tide giba tries to mount a comeback but
he eventually Falls to Naruto out Shadow
cloning him giba had so many
opportunities to close out the match but
he got cocky I find it ironic he lost
his shadow clones when it was he who
opened with this version of that
technique
[Music]
thank you
speaking of losing to your own technique
how about killua versus real velt
[Applause]
Heaven's arena is memorable for a lot of
fights we have the whole gun versus
hisoka thing but often lost in the
footnotes is this minor confrontation
between kilua and real velt it's not too
long of a fight and it's not much of a
fight in the first place actually
honestly it's mostly just real world
sizing up kirua and attempting to attack
him with the outrageously named twin
snake whips the whole time hirua
remained composed and simply counted his
adversaries attack skillfully eventually
rail belt pulls out all the stops and
unveils his secret technique Thunder
snake unfortunately for him though kilua
was unfazed by his electricity but not
him he gets caught in his own technique
and it was what kinawa uses to finish
him off losing to your own technique
never feels good especially not in front
of Spectators right after you so proudly
talked it up
okay
oh this is still sticking off
finally it's Eisen beating everyone
[Music]
yes finishing off with one of my
personal memorable moments in Shonen
izen versus everyone can mean a lot of
things however while the whole troll
moment in garakura town is a contender
you know after everyone unloaded on Momo
of all people but I think that his
defeat of Ichigo and arengi is something
else to be fair both Ichigo and renji
had just been to Helen Back with
stopping rookia's execution still the
anime pulled out all the stops to make
it seem like they had a chance to win at
all the wrapped up renji still had a bit
of fight left in him and he and Ichigo
even cooked up an amazing plan to beat I
said ichigo's theme plays they go at it
and Eisen stops ichigo's sword with a
finger then proceeds to one shot both of
them the music ends and is literally
never heard of in the anime again at
least that version of number one it's
not ichigo's first defeat against a
tough foe but this was a time when he
just received such a big spike in power
coming off a win against biakuya
momentum is completely at his side and
boom
that's it for my list most embarrassing
defeats in anime for me these are my
favorites still I'm actually interested
in your opinion on the worst and most
embarrassing defeats so do make sure you
keep those comments coming in on that
and don't forget to check out our
sponsor's slickdeal for the best deals
and discounts while shopping online you
can download the extension by using the
link in the description I hope you can
also come over to videotube's other
social media channels as well Discord
Instagram and patreon are all available
in the description box as usual like And
subscribe if you like what you're seeing
and I'd love to see you again for the
next video thank you and see you next
time